most sabar beings are already struggling
to put food on the table
these women are grateful for any kind of
assistance years of drought rising
inflation and now coronavirus have seen
food prices saw several families are now
eating less many say they know not much
will change until lockdown restrictions
are eased or scrapped in early May we
know the virus is killing people so we
are waiting for that tweets and we are
we we are not doctors
we an onus is we are no the whatever so
we are waiting for what we're waiting
for that twist to be to get finished
after it finished we'll see what is
going to happen next
the World Food Program says half of the
bobby's population needs food aid a
poverty assessment done by the
government and aid agencies last year
found nearly 80% of families in urban
areas are hungry
local milling companies tried to cope
with what's available the pandemic has
made it difficult to buy more grain from
abroad some of these countries on
lockdown is not the export ban but what
it simply done is that the
infrastructure the whole system of
exporting is no ceased to operate also
and some of the ships that are bringing
a consignment decide are not subjected
to quarantine devastation they arrive so
this has slowed down the the importation
of grain families in rural areas are
also struggling the rains have been
erratic many haven't managed to grow
much food now the global health crisis
is making more families here vulnerable
priority is given to the sick and the
elderly and even here people are being
encouraged to practice social distancing
but masks and gloves and hand sanitizers
are in short supply and that's the case
all over the country zubaba is
unofficial unemployment rate is more
than 80 percent
most people live hand-to-mouth the
government is vulnerable households will
receive cash transfers over the next
three months that's less than $10 per
person every month
businesses have been told by the state
not to increase the prices of basic
commodities but in previous years
whenever an official price freeze was
imposed
he led to panic buying shortages and
even more frustration harder Matassa al
Jazeera Zimbabwe